Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Ma che ve devo dì?
Che - che volete?
- Oh, insomma?
- Che cosa? - Sto talk?
- No, io non lo faccio il Talk.
Eh certo, ti tocca fare il talk!
Il bollino rosso ti aspetta.
- No, io nel bollino rosso
non ci voglio andare.
No no no, guarda che è pieno di vision,
è pieno di mission, no no.
- Anche senza impegno,
anche senza impegno.
Se ci entro, però, nel bollino rosso,
ci entro senza impegno.
Lo faccio senza impegno.
- Senza impegno, vieni vieni vieni.
- Però non sono uno speaker eh,
voglio chiarirla questa cosa
- Ma ci penso io, ci penso io.
Io mi occupo di marketing
aziendale, di comunicazione.
Mi ha mandato Dio,
vista la fine del mondo.
Ma tu come stai? Mi hai detto poco bene.
- Poco bene sì, si vede eh? Poco bene.
- E allora tu, presentati, dicci chi sei.
- Hanno visto chi sono,
non sono uno speaker.
- No no no: il tuo curriculum!
Nome del candidato: - Niccolò
- La tastiera legge solo
caratteri alfanumerici!
- Nicolò, con una c.
- Il problema è l’accento sulla o finale.
- Niccolo! - Piccolo?
- No, dico: Niccolo! Almeno niccolo…
- La correzione automatica
suggerisce "Piccolo"
- Sì però piccolo non mi sembra
esattamente un nome, ecco.
- Ma tu non essere pignolo,
piccolo è un nome così tenero!
Scrivi piccolo.
- Eh vabbè e allora scrivi piccolo.
- Piacere, Piccolo.
- Cognome? - FettarappaSan.
E va bene, solo fetta.
- È perfetto: piacere, Piccolo Fetta.
E devi dire: piacere! - Piacere!
- E vai! Hobby? - Suicidio - Yoga.
- Descriviti con una parola: Fallimento.
- Dinamico, alto quoziente
intellettivo, Piccolo Fetta.
Ti si legge negli occhi, Piccolo Fetta.
Stato civile?
- Stato civile? Stato civile?
Ma chi è mai stato civile,
nello stato civile?
Stato civile... Celibe, sono!
- No no no, celibe non piace alle aziende.
Dì qualcosa sul tuo gender!
Sarai un po’ gender fluid? gender liquid?
Di che sesso è la tua mente?
Il tuo naso, le tue mani
sono chiaramente da frocio.
Vai, corri, scappa all’estero!
Vai in Erasmus, che qui
non c’è trippa per gatti!
- Eh no. - Eh, qui
non c’è trippa per gatti
- No no
- Qui 'n c’è trippa per gatti,
qui 'n c’è trippa per gatti,...
Sta imparando che qui
c’è trippa per gatti.
Ma vai agli open day!
Fatti un master! - Un master?
Non senti l’esigenza
del master? - Il master!
- L’urgenza del master? - Il master!
Il bisogno viscerale
del master! - Un master!
In che ce lo prendiamo,
questo master? - Un master!
- Che ti piace? - Aahh
- Che ti appassiona? - Il master!
Ooooooooooh!
- Che ti piace? - Che mi piace?
- La macarena.
(Risate)
- La macarena?
A mi me gusta bailar la macarena.
Eh vabbè, allora
specializzati in macarena:
un bel master in macarena!
Na, na na na, na na na, macarena;
na na na na na na cosa buena;
na na na na na na macarena,
eeeeh macarena!
- Pausa! Tiè va, fuma.
- Ah grazie, tanto è legale?
- Oooh, ormai è tutto legale.
- Sai una cosa? Dovresti
lavorare su te stesso.
- Dovrei lavorare su me stesso,
me lo dico sempre anche io
- Ma lo sai perchè? Stai impaludato,
infognato nella comfort zone.
- Si vede tanto? - Eh sì,
ce stai come nelle sabbie mobili.
- Ti devi aprire: apri! Apri! Apri!
- Che ne so, apri la mente, no?
- Ma che cazzo stai a dì?
Te devi apra partita IVA!
- La partita IVA? Ah certo,
perchè la vita è quella no?
Tu nasci, te apri na partita IVA e muori!
- Bravo! Ma lo stai a vedè
il telegiornale?
Breaking news, quanti morti Piccolo Fetta?
52, 63, 74.
E quanto sono morti? Sono tutti morti,
o un po’ morti o un po’ vivi?
E i feriti, i mutilati, il G8,
il calciomercato,
i sondaggi elettorali!
I sondaggi elettorali!
Corri e informati, Piccolo Fetta!
Corri informato!
E pausa.
- E da fumare? Che prima…
- Tieni, tieni! fuma, fuma.
- Che vuoi un tiro?
- Ma mica so coglione come te!
- Ma 'nfatti - Fuma, fuma.
Senti, hai pensato un minimo
a quello che ti ho detto prima?
Si, sto facendo tutto un mio percorso,
Me sto mettendo solo -
Ma chi prendi in giro, guarda:
la comfort zone,
ci sto ancora immerso dentro,
ma quella bastarda mi segue!
- Io la mattina mi sveglio,
e quella bastarda mi segue.
- Sì, sì:
ma quanti aperitivi hai fatto,
dall’ultima volta che ci siamo visti?
- Eh uno…
- Uno aperitivo? E con chi?
- Con la fidanzatina.
- E la fidanzatina fa la commercialista?
- Non ha neanche la partita IVA.
- E allora è stato un aperitivo
buttato, sprecato.
- Vai! Sky, Fastweb,
Mediaset Premium a 29
invece che 49 euro al mese,
tutto il calcio che vuoi,
navighi senza limiti Piccolo Fetta,
ordini cibo a domicilio,
il cibo cinese, thailandese, messicano.
Ma ce lo guardiamo un bel porno
con le ragazzine nude su YouPorn?
- No le ragazzine no!
- Guarda 'ste tette, Piccolo Fetta!
- No, le tette no!
- Stai sempre a pensare al sesso?
- Al TEDx, le tette no!
- Sei un sessuomane! - No, niente tette!
- Sei un erotomane! - No, non è vero!
- Sei un porco, piccolo fetta!
- Un po’ sì  - E adesso dicci chi sei!
- Salve a tutti, sono Piccolo Fetta.
Nella vita ho sempre dato il peggio di me,
non ho alcuna ambizione,
alcun talento, alcun merito.
Vi inoltro il mio curriculum vitae,
tragicamente scarno.
Le mie esperienze lavorative fanno ridere,
infatti so bene che il mercato
del lavoro mi massacrerà.
Come dice? Tra venti anni come mi vedo?
Ehhhhhh,
Ehhhhh,
si può scrivere ehhhhhh?
No? Ah.
Allora, spero sepolto
sotto ad una modesta lapide.
- Scriviamo aspirante manager?
- Sì sembra coerente proprio. Paro paro.
- Piccolo Fetta, qual è l’idolo
a cui tu ti ispiri?
- L’idolo? - L’idolo!
- Dico, ci fosse no? Un messia,
un patriarca dei nostri tempi!
Uno che faccia un miracolo,
uno che la sa lunga!
- Steve! - Steve chi? - Steve Jobs!
- Ehhh, lo vedi che mi fido bene di te.
Il buon vecchio Steve, sì!
The good old Steve!
Lui sì, che aveva il giusto mindset.
Lui sì, che entrava in feeling
con il suo team.
- E tu? - Che?
- Perché non provi a entrare
in feeling col tuo team?
- Col team? - Eh, sì.
- Nel bollo rosso? - Nel bollo rosso.
- Eh, vabbè. Ci provo.
Salve a tutti, sono Piccolo Fetta,
e come sapete il mondo sta per finire…
- Però io ti ho detto di fare come Steve.
- Ah, proprio come Steve?
- Eh sì, ma a Piccolo Fetta
non gliene frega niente.
Devi fare come Steve.
- Bastava specificarlo, però, dirlo.
Io ci mettevo un attimo:
ho studiato, per farlo.
Sono un attore,
basta che uno esce da quello che è
ed entra nell’oggetto da interpretare.
Io esco da Piccolo Fetta,
ed entro in Steve Jobs.
Fuori Piccolo Fetta, dentro Steve Jobs.
Fuori Piccolo Fetta,
Steve Jobs, St..Steve Jobs.
Now… Mestre…Steve…Ehm…
Hi... Ahi ahi ahi...
(Risate)
Hi guys….
How do you do…
This is
the new iPhone.
(Risate)
Do you like it?
(Risate) (Piange)
Bravo, infatti! Bravo!
Ma bravo de che,
mi prendi in giro? (Applausi)
Eh mo scatta pure l’applauso così,
guarda come è imbarazzante, mortificante.
No, pausa, pausa Matteo:
ho bisogno di un minuto.
- Dai, dai non fare così
- M'hai fatto pure mette
nel bollo rosso, mi hai fatto mettere!
Senza che me ne accorgevo
sono diventato uno speaker pure io.
C’avevo la vision..
Io non lo so parlare l’inglese,
ma che me fai fa, è mortificante.
Stavano li, facevano ha ha ha
Steve Jobs: questi vogliono Steve Jobs?
Oh, ma io non lo so fa Steve Jobs!
Io sono Piccolo Fetta!
Ma uno se non nasce nella Silicon Valley,
ma che deve fà in sta vita?
Ma se non so programmare le app,
tutte 'ste app che c’hanno tutti,
ma io che devo fare?
Io non sono nato nella Silicon Valley.
Io sono Piccolo Fetta,
non sono Steve Jobs!
Questi vogliono Steve Jobs?
Volete Steve Jobs? Volete Steve Jobs?
Sempre Steve Jobs? Eterni Steve Jobs.
Io non lo so fà.
Io non lo so fà, Steve Jobs.
Io sono Piccolo Fetta.
Volete Steve Jobs? Io non faccio il talk.
E io vado dal dinosauro! Eh sì.
- Scusate, scusate - Eh no,
- Scusate, si è emozionato.
Questa cosa di Steve Jobs
lo tocca particolarmente:
non è nato nella Silicon Valley.
Potete far finta di entrare
in feeling con lui
a prescindere, anche se
non è Steve Jobs? Dite sì.
- (Pubblico) Siii
- Hai visto con quanto entusiasmo?
- No, io non rientro,
perchè come rientro questi vogliono
che io faccia Steve Jobs.
Non lo so fa Steve Jobs!
Io vado dentro al dinosauro!
No no, vogliono proprio
Piccolo Fetta, non è vero?
- (Pubblico): Sììì
- Bravi grazie. Hai visto? Che hai fatto?
-Ho fatto il cattivo.
È che questa cosa della Silicon Valley
mi tocca, è una questione delicata…
- Eh lo so, però guarda:
adesso ce li hai tutti in feeling.
Adesso fai il tuo bel talk!
Adesso io faccio un talk.
Ma che bello! Wow! Mestre TEDx!
Ma che roba! Ma che esperienza!
Jurassic Park! Extinction! Apocalisse!
Wow! bello, bello, bello.
Mi sono divertito.
Posso dire che mi sono
divertito tantissimo?
Con questi ragazzi qua
che fanno le loro cose:
scappano, corrono,
ognuno con una sua storia,
ognuno con un suo dream, una sua vision.
Bello bello bello.
Poi questi che corrono,
sudano, un sacco di sudore.
Io, quando vedo tutto questo
sudore imprenditoriale, mi esalto!
Cioè, quando vedo questa gioventù
così frizzantella, auto imprenditoriale,
c'ho le sinapsi che fanno proprio -
Senti qua, senti che odore
di Confindustria che c'è qui, eh?
Mamma mia come si è riscaldato l'ambiente!
E vabbè vabbè vabbè.
E niente: chi sono io? Perché sono qua?
Io sono chiacchierone, insomma,
sono qui per parlare, per fare un talk,
per raccontarvi la mia vision!
La mia mission! La mia -
Il mio concept di apocalisse.
Cioè, cosa è l'Apocalisse?
What is Apocalisse?
Beh it’s easy, è facile!
L'Apocalisse è una cosa…
Wow! No?
Ma è anche una cosa terra terra,
cioè che deve tornare utile
in termini di spendibilità economica.
Non so se mi spiego.
Allora, per l'ultimo giorno
dell'umanità cosa facciamo?
It’s easy, semplice:
organizziamo un Apo-Expo.
Cioè un'apocalisse Expo!
Cioè, praticamente
mettiamo tutti degli stand
in cui esponiamo le eccellenze italiane,
ovverosia il cibo, il food!
Se vai fuori all'estero,
tutti sanno parlare del cibo italiano.
Tu metti i panini,
metti un sacco di panini,
così il turista tedesco è felice!
Prendi due fette di pane,
ci metti dentro uno di questi ragazzini
un po' intellettualoni, con le loro idee,
e fai felice il turista tedesco
che va via mangiando
l’intellettualino di sinistra.
E siamo tutti quanti felici, o no?
Perché Dio si compiace del made in Italy!
E poi, vedi come il giorno
del Giudizio Universale
ci piazza tutti in pole position!
Piccolo Fetta, tutto è pronto
per il Giudizio Universale!
Laureati!
Avete fatto fare sacrifici
ai vostri genitori
per la vostra insaziabile
sete di erudizione?
Bravi, bbravi, bravi, bravi!!
Adesso, però, vi tocca pagare!
Neee-nooo, neee-nooo.
Abitano dei laureati,
in questo condominio?
Cinque, sei, vivono tutti
nella stessa stanza!
Buttali dentro! Rastrella, rastrella.
Guarda quello, sta in subaffitto!
Butta dentro! Neee-nooo, neee-nooo.
- Fermo, questo che è?
- Questa è una biblioteca!
- Uscite con le tesi in alto!
- Questi stavano ancora a scrivere poesie!
- Ah, si sentono i poeti romantici?
- Glielo faccio vedere io,
lo Sturm und Drang!
Neee-nooo, neee-nooo.
- Oddio Oddio no - Che è? che è?
È un centro sociale!
Esistono ancora? Zecche bastarde!
Butta dentro! Questo pensa de stà -
Woodstock è da un’altra parte!
Butta dentro!
Maledetti bastardi - Neee-nooo, neee-nooo.
Laureati, cominciamo con una domanda:
che cosa è il lavoro?
Non sapete che cos'è il lavoro?
Ve lo diciamo noi, che cos'è il lavoro!
Ah, sì. Il lavoro, oggi, non esiste!
Weeeeeeeee!
No no, calma laureati, calma!
Oggi esiste un'altra piccola cosina,
che si chiama job.
La differenza fra lavoro
e job è sostanziale,
ed è la stessa essenziale differenza
che c'è tra mela e apple,
o tra cane e dog.
Insomma, laureati, imparate questa parola,
imparate l'inglese: job! job! job!
Il job è molto più che un lavoro:
il job è uno stile di vita.
Quando fate job,
non fate più job per un padrone,
com'era con il lavoro:
fate job per voi stessi!
Il job è una grande occasione,
un grande favore
che voi fate a voi stessi.
Evviva il job! Evviva il job!
Evviva il job! Stay hungry: stay foolish!
- Cari laureati, sfortunatamente per voi
c'è un solo job in palio questa sera,
quindi sotto a chi tocca:
dovete meritarvelo!
- Comincia il Giudizio Universale.
- Il Colloquio Universale!
Chi entrerà nel "Grande mercato di Dio"?
Su su su: disponetevi in due file
secondo il vostro ordinamento
sessuale tradizionale,
ripetiamo tutti in coro: "tradizionale".
Quello? Inclassificato: via!
Laureati, lo sentite questo rumore?
È il rumore del mercato!
Il mercato che vi brama,
il mercato che vi sbrana.
E allora sotto a chi tocca!
Contratto a progetto!
Contratto a martirio!
Cococo! cocopro! Alternanza scuola lavoro!
Dài, buttali dentro! Aiutooooooooo!
Ciao Ciccino, dimmi un po':
tu in cosa ti sei laureato?
- Io ho studiato filosofia!
- Bella, filosofia: in un'altra vita,
l'avrei studiata pure io:
ma tu che ti sei laureato in filosofia
devi sapere che un futuro
non ce l'hai manco alle spalle.
Non parlarmi di futuro, ah ah!
Dentro, nel tritacarne!
Aaaaaaah! Non la voglio fare la start up!
Non mi va, di fare la start up!
Amore mio, ma tocca a tutti, prima o poi:
è una fase della vita.
- Tu quanto sei flessibile?
- Facci vedere un po' di flessibilità.
-Beh, bella performance. Le faremo sapere!
- Le faremo sapere! Mammaaaaaaa
- O Gesù, Gesù, Gesù!
E tu, mio disoccupato amico,
cosa ti fa credere di essere meritevole
di entrare nel grande mercato di Dio?
- Dicci un po: hai una laurea? - Sì, beh…
Dicci dicci dicci:
in cosa ti sei laureato?
(Sussurra) DAMS
No no, vieni vieni: dillo ad alta voce.
- DAMS! - Umiliati di più:
dì tutta la sigla.
- Discipline artistiche,
musica e spettacolo.
- Spe Spe Spe? Spettacolo!
C’era pure spettacolo!
Ma io non l'ho fatto apposta.
Ce l'ho messa tutta,
per laurearmi fuori corso.
- Pure fuori corso, è andato! - Sììì
- Mamma e papà ti portano
proprio sul palmo di mano.
- Sìì, la mia tesi ha pure preso la lode!
- No, vabbè: DAMS fuori corso con la lode?
- Ma sei un genietto? - Sììì
- Stupralo questo,
stupralo! Buttalo di là.
Questo che sia di monito per tutti:
vai con la musica!
L'Italia è piena di università
piene di laureati da mietere!
Vai con la strage!
(Distruggono tutto)
La fuga dei cervelli pijatevela!
- Questo? - Questo?
Lancio libero:  Freelance!
Grazie, grazie.
(Applausi)